Joe starts off this hour in Orlando hi
Joe how are you are they better than I
deserve good how can I help ya well I uh
I'm hoping to be able to buy a home
pretty soon and uh I'm I'm currently
renting and my lease is up in April
however um you know with my budget by
then I'll have about 10 to 12 percent
maybe closer to 15 in terms of being
able to put the down payment so uh so
what I'm considering doing is and what
kind of done in the past is use um
credit cards with 0% APR for 12 or 18
months arm to be able to all I've done
in the past is just get the little
cashback bonuses and try to build my
credit and then I pay it down before I
ever pay any interest and so what I'm
thinking about doing is to kind of run
up a balance pay as many bills as I can
with a credit card arm and then be able
to have more cash more liquidity to make
the down payment on the house in April
so essentially you want to borrow extra
on the credit cards in order to have a
bigger down payment yeah but I mean
without add M&S the net result of your
odd that's the net result of your idea
what do you mean you're borrowing on
credit cards to increase the size of
your down payment sure yes yeah yeah
yeah no I would never tell anyone to
borrow their down payment on a credit
card even if even if I won't have to
deal with any interest because I wasn't
you dealing with any I'm dealing with no
interest as your theory before your life
happens
sure there are home improvements or
something like that you know I realize I
just I'm trying to avoid the mortgage
insurance yeah I want you to I'd love
for you to avoid that but I'm okay when
you're buying and having a little PMI
for a period of time you may have to
refinance to get rid of it or when you
pay it down you may have to pay an
appraisal to get rid of it but I'd
rather do that listen there's no good
that comes from playing footsie with
these credit card companies
I just don't meet any millionaires that
say Dave you know I screwed around with
credit cards and I had all these systems
and plans using credit cards to my
advantage and it causes me to be build
wealth
never find that ever when I'm meeting
with millionaires instead what I meet
our guys that had really good intentions
and had a really good theory but then
life came up and interrupted their
theory and you end up with a bunch of
credit card debt while you own a house
and it's you know it's rolled over now
they're charging you interest you're
going dadgum that was dumb because you
did you can't see what all's coming in
the future so just just be calm just
just do it the right way do it the way
your grandmother would do it or your
great grandmother would do it go slow
I'm assuming the way you're talking that
you're out of debt now um mostly I have
a little bit of student loan debt um but
and I was considering I wasn't really um
totally devoted to the idea of buying a
house because I liked what I was renting
well my landlord said my rent was going
up by $75 a month and I know my mortgage
payment would be at least $150 less than
that or if I am able to put 20% down so
or or less I mean these are way it's a
new rent costs are going up because
housing values are going up yeah it's
also it's also okay to go and rent
somewhere else yeah I I just I mean with
I've pets and it's a good location and
I'm trying to find a house that would be
near my car you know starting about 40
okay and you're single I'm single
okay all right listen head out you're
going to you know when you were a kid
did you ever run so fast you tripped
over your own feet all the time that's
what this sounds like
well I'm in a hurry yeah yeah I know to
make some moves and it's an investment
obviously oh no no no no you can start
you you know the first part was correct
the second part is you're in a hurry
you're in hurry yeah you feel pinched
you feel like you hadn't got our bills
and I want you to get some other options
I want you to go find some other places
to live as a possibility I want you to
think about what extra what else you've
got you can sell to clear this but no
I'm not going to tell you to borrow on a
credit card in order to avoid PMI by
putting an additional down payment it's
a really really really bad idea and Joe
of course what we teach folks is to be
completely debt-free before you
bye and have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses plus your down
payment I don't think I'm hearing that
and I think if I'm not hearing that that
my advice would be real simple and it
would be to either work something out
with your landlord or move and rent
front of the year and let's get the
student loan paid off let's get a good
emergency fund bill let's get the rest
of this downpayment bill and don't run
so fast you trip over your feet you got
time to do this right if you just slow
down a little bit but if you do it wrong
it's going to cost you and you get the
you get those penalty steps back or in
the case of tripping over your own feet
it's called skinned hands and skin to
knees which is what I always did when I
wasn't because I wasn't that coordinated
I'm out there running and tripped over
and because I'm going too fast you get
going too fast downhill you fall off I
got one of those hoverboards and I fell
off that thing the other day and I'm
running at like a thousand miles an hour
trying to keep from crashing forward
doing that exact same thing and busting
my hands and my knees and everything
else
I stayed up right thank goodness but you
know it's the same exact thing
same exact thing so anyway hey man
thanks for the call hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim
Oh